le revenu universel fait son retour dans
le débat public en espagne en allemagne
mais aussi en corse où l'expérimentation
d'un tel projet a été voté
objectif explorer toutes les pistes
permettant de renforcer les solidarités
suite à la crise ducobu 19,6 le revenu
universel fait la une aujourd'hui
saviez vous que ce concept date de 1516
à cette époque l'humaniste anglais
thomas more décrit une société ou un
revenu de subsistance serait assurée
pour tous de la naissance à la mort
indépendamment du travail
une utopie reprise ensuite par des
philosophes ou des économistes et même
dans les années 90 par des chefs
d'entreprises français revenu
d'existence pour reprendre de l'ambré
sont ces rémunérer les personnes parce
qu'elles existent et non pour exister
une société ou un revenu de subsistance
serait assurée où le travail ne serait
pas une finalité en soi une théorie
idéaliste diront certains une obligation
pour ce collectif de chômeurs européens
en 1999
parmi les revendications communes autres
pays la plus importante
un revenu de base pour la dignité
équivalent à 1200 euros soit 7200 francs
afin de participer pleinement à la vie
sociale culturelle et politique de
l'europe
le temps passe et l'utopie devient un
programme politique
on propose un revenu universel pour que
tous les gens même s'ils perdent leur
emploi puissent accompagner
il faut qu'on ait un revenu qui soit
supérieur au revenu minimum qui permette
aux gens dès l'âge de 18 ans parce que
les jeunes sont très concernés de
pouvoir vivre décemment
cinq ans plus tard même programme de
politique européenne
mais du côté du parti de christine
boutin
nous proposons la création d'un revenu
de base européen qui empêche européen
gilbert aucun et empêche à tous de ne
jamais tomber dans l'extrême précarité
en 2017 le revenu universel devient même
l'argument principal de campagne de
benoît hamon candidat à la primaire de
la gauche
la révolution numérique doit nous amener
à ce que le travail soit plus rare et le
revenu universel permet de choisir de
réduire son temps de travail parce qu'on
sait qu'on ne perdra pas de pouvoir
d'achat mais le candidat à la
présidentielle sera obligé de
transformer son idée de revenu universel
en un revenu de base fusionnant les
aides sociales et uniquement à
destination des plus pauvres
benoît hamon présentait aujourd'hui son
programme on parle moins du revenu
universel et un peu plus du travail et
de l'emploi
une proposition bien loin du projet
initial qui concernait alors tous les
français et c'est cette formule du
revenu universel plus vraiment universel
donc mais plutôt d'une aide sociale aux
plus pauvres qui est reprise aujourd'hui
en pleine crise économique
[Musique]